carlos carrasco starting for the mets
tonight missed most of the season with a
right hamstring tear has been better of
late particularly his last two starts
getting downward movement on that
changeup but something to watch the
first inning remains a problem for
carrasco a 15 era in the first inning
here's gene segura and the pitch swung
on belton deep left field forget about
it that is gone and gene segura first
ball swinging has hobart off of carrasco
and the phillies take the early lead
it's one to nothing 13th homer of the
year for gene segura oh my
95 mile an hour fastball middle of the
plate and he's ready to go
they might have to change the panels on
that one
out in left field because that hit the
that hit hard 113 off the bat there is
the home run hat you gotta wear it and
it brings up bryce harper swinging a
ground ball through the vacated
shortstop spot there's a base hit
barrel to it
nice and easy ground ball through for a
base hit and a 14-game hitting streak
for bryce harper here's jt ramirez a
huge part of what the philly's doing he
bats in their cleanup spot hit weakly to
carrasco fires to second for one bias
back to first double play
nicely turn
a one four three double play on the hill
for the phillies is erin nola
well this guy's having a little bit of a
strange season uh he's their ace and he
was until wheeler has been dominant but
nola is a big part of his game is
spinning the baseball and his secondary
stuff but
if he's going to have the kind of game
that the phillies want him to have that
goes back to the old nola look for his
fastball command especially early on
down in the first inning form brandon
nimmo
swinging a miss and he strikes out nemo
first k of the night for aaron nola two
down and he get a breaking ball and
swings over the top two down here in the
last of the first for francisco lindor
swinging a miss and he strikes out
lender back to that case for nola enjoys
a one two three first freddie galvez
will now step in mccutcheon at second
two outs top of the second here 2-2
pitch
lifted in the air into center field nemo
on the run coming in dives and makes the
catch
terrific catch by brandon nimmo in
center field that saved a run
mccutcheon would have scored if that
ball dropped
nemo though
with the dive in his glove for the third
and final out here in the top of the
second so they're on the quarters and
here's mccann with a chance to get the
mets on the board
mccann strikes out and nola does indeed
get out of the jam it was a taxing
inning but he gets out of it unscathed
one down here in the third as nola
struck out and here is herrera
the end of the shift on the right side
bias from the backhand gets it there in
time nice play
by javi baez who has spent the bulk of
his career on the other side of the
infield
not here at city field and with the mets
and a good backhanded play against the
grain a magician in every sense of the
word when he's in the field here's gene
segura who homered on the first pitch he
saw in the first inning here's the swing
of the drive to deep left it's a carbon
copy he's gone deep again
gene segura in nearly the same spot with
another solo home run his second of the
night his 14th of the year
and it's two nothing phillies who are
you
two hats are going on two home runs for
gene segura 13 and 14 of the year one
down in the third inning yeah five
strikeouts for aaron nola through the
first two in the third innings
struck him out foul tipped into the
catcher's mitt that's six strikeouts for
nola two down spun the breaking ball got
the k two down in the third and here is
brandon nimmo
that's strike three and make it seven
strikeouts for nola
who has
touched him twice for home runs in the
first and in the third both solo shots
is up here with two on and two down
here's the drive down the left field
line on the run is mcneil he'll get
there to make the running catch and nz
inning hung up long enough
for mcneil to run it down here comes
carrasco to hit for himself his second a
b of this game
that is strike three and it's the ninth
strikeout of this game for nola brandon
nimmo the batter
here's the drive out towards deep right
field back goes harper it's off the bat
in nimmo and it's off the wall
limo is thinking three headed in that
direction so is the throw head first
he's got himself a triple
wall ball to right center field
and standing at third is brandon nemo
and francisco lindor with nimmo 90 feet
away
even closer now with one out
on the ground right side segura's got
one play it's at first and in the back
door from third comes nemo metzer on the
board it's 2-1 philadelphia miller third
base with the phillies on top two to one
brings up freddie galvez swung on and
yanked over the leap of vr it's a fair
ball down the left field line and into
score is miller on his way to second is
galves and he's got himself an rbi
double it's now three to one two down
and brings up bryce harper two on here's
the pitch swinging to drive down the
right field line that is in there for a
base hit it'll go to the corner galvez
will score around third is o'double
they'll wave him to the plate it's a
two-run double from bryce harper
phillies with a three spot here in the
seventh now lead the bets five to one or
lead off single for bias it'll bring up
jeff mcneil his pitch from [ __ ] rod to
mcneil swung on in line to his left
center field and mccutchen coming on
dives and he caught it wow andrew
mccutchen laying out and takes a hit
away from jeff mcneal what a play
and they're going to go check on him
looks like he is all right here comes
dom smith
off the bench to the pitch hit with two
outs
up the middle that'll find its way into
right center field to base hit
by is being waved around he'll score
and the mets collect their second run of
the evening see if the mets can get
something going here in the bottom of
the eighth inning against nearest nemo
tripled his last time up this
is out to deep right and this is gone
brandon nemo with a home run brings the
mets closer it's now five to three
and kennedy finished off last night's
game four the phillies trying to do the
same in game two kevin pallar off the
bench swinging a pop-up nice shadow
right going out segura coming on harper
harper calling he's got it the ball
game's over phillies have won their
fourth in a row they keep the pressure
on the braves
and perhaps
they'll wake up tomorrow
one game out of first place in the
national league east after this 5-3 win
and what a win right there